sono diventata un attivista quando avevo
14 anni e in quello stesso periodo ho
abbracciato il veganismo passando da
Un'alimentazione vegetariana che ho
seguito da quando ne avevo appena 10 il
mio lavoro mi ha messa nelle condizioni
di rendermi conto che le persone Appena
Scoprono che sono vegana instaurano
immediatamente un rapporto di sfida con
me Ecco perché oggi voglio cimentarmi
nell'impresa di introdurre loro questo
mondo partendo dal punto di vista che
hanno cioè spiegando a una persona
onnivora rispondendo alle sue domande
perché io ho scelto di combattere per la
liberazione animale la prima
argomentazione che è interessante
analizzare è che esiste una catena
alimentare composta da una preda e un
predatore quindi non rispettarla sarebbe
innaturale se non fosse che il leone si
ciba della gazzella perché nell'ambiente
in cui si trova soglia strettamente
necessario per sopravvivere quindi la
descrizione del suo modo di vivere non è
di certo una scusa per imitare il suo
comportamento visto che disponiamo di
moltissime alternative che ci permettono
di ridefinire il nostro rapporto con gli
animali che per cultura mangiamo questa
è la ragione per cui frasi come Ma se tu
ti trovassi su un'isola deserta con un
maiale senza provviste cosa faresti non
hanno alcun significato perché sviano
intenzionalmente il senso del discorso
ignorando che nella realtà in cui sono
pronunciate abbiamo supermercati
di facilitazioni che ci permettono
appunto di compiere una scelta diversa
ma gli animali questa scelta diversa non
potrebbero compiarla altrettanto O mi
sbaglio non hanno raziocinio e di
conseguenza Noi siamo superiori a loro e
mi colpisce molto come constatazione in
quanto
l'intelligenza la forza o tanti altri
attributi attributi sono utili agli
animali per sopravvivere quindi mi pare
quanto più antitetico e ironico
interpretarli come una giustificazione
per dominare togliere la vita degli
individui indipendentemente dalla specie
quando è perfettamente evitabile allo
stesso modo io mi sentirei di sfruttare
Queste capacità per che so smentire
qualche affermazione
antropocentrica dello stesso corde
calibro iniziamo con ma è dall'alba dei
tempi che si mangia la carne Se non
fosse che è pure dall'alba dei tempi che
si fa la guerra Eppure di certo non
siamo fan di questa no
poi ci sarebbe anche noi abbiamo i
canini per mangiare la carne che oltre a
essere scientificamente discutibile e
anche parecchio problematica sotto il
punto di vista di una fallacia logica Se
volessimo leggerla con questa chiave di
lettura Infatti l'essenzialismo
biologico
consiste nel utilizzare delle
caratteristiche che ci vengono date
dalla natura dalla nostra genetica per
garantire la giustezza delle
implicazioni che attribuiamo a esse un
altro esempio potrebbe essere in chiave
umana in chiave in chiave se vogliamo
anche femminista le donne devono Badare
alla prole Non fare nient'altro della
loro esistenza perché loro la
partoriscono
Sì
parlando invece di
un'altra affermazione potremmo
sicuramente pensare al fatto che il
cervello umano si è evoluto grazie alla
carne che al contrario della precedente
è vera Tuttavia dobbiamo pensare che
anche opere grandiose come le piramidi o
il Colosseo sono state costruite grazie
alla manodopera schiavile quindi io non
credo che la strada giusta da prendere
come società per stabilire una morale
che sia veramente inclusiva nei
confronti di tutti gli esseri viventi
possa consistere nel esaltare il passato
e così autorizzarlo a ripetersi
Comunque sia c'è anche possibilità di
concentrarsi sul futuro perché non ci
proiettiamo su un altro tema che è
sicuramente il tasto dolente per le
persone vegane parlo della
sperimentazione animale che ovviamente
se non avessimo avuto ci avrebbe privato
di moltissime scoperte in ambito medico
che abbiamo
utilizzato per salvare innumerevoli vite
Tuttavia gli studi di Stefano Cagno
membro del comitato scientifico è qui
vita hanno dimostrato come le sostanze
somministrate
agli animali hanno effetti diversi in
base alla specie di questi ultimi Ciò
significa che su un essere umano
Potrebbero essere potenzialmente
benefiche su un animale di un'altra
specie nocive
viceversa per cui data la scarsa
affidabilità di questo metodo è
sicuramente
necessario andare oltre sorpassarlo e
scegliere un innovazione più
si potrebbe dire etica e soprattutto
efficace
allo stesso modo io vorrei dire un'altra
cosa ovvero E se fosse l'unica strada
che noi abbiamo per salvare gli esseri
umani se di nuovo
dovessimo collegarci a un altro tallone
d'Achille presuntamente tale delle
persone vegane ovvero che pure Loro
uccidono per via dei pesticidi che
servono per proteggere le piante che
consumano a questo io vorrei rispondere
dando la definizione di veganismo che
sarebbe il cercare di limitare con tale
stile di vita al massimo estendibile la
crudeltà da infliggere agli animali nei
limiti però del praticabile e
soprattutto del possibile e quindi io mi
chiedo per quale motivo il non avere la
disponibilità materiale di risolvere
la questione della Sofferenza animale
dovrebbe essere in qualche modo una
scusa per fregarsene completamente ed
essere a posto con il Non fare il minimo
indispensabile per
evitarla anche per quello che invece
è possibile al momento Quindi
passati questi punti sarebbe anche
interessante parlare delle piante perché
alla fine sappiamo bene che
noi persone vegane siamo spesso
insultate di ucciderle anche le piante
sono vive e però non lo sono come un
essere Senziente perché non disponendo
di un sistema nervoso non hanno una
coscienza di conseguenza non temono di
certo di essere uccise per finire nel
nostro piatto ma anche in questo caso
ammettiamo che preoccupazione sia
differente le persone onnivore non
potrebbero comunque lamentarsi perché ne
uccidono molte più di noi
infatti
nella dieta giornaliera di quest'ultime
le una quantità di vegetali viene
assunta direttamente grazie ai pasti a
base di questi E poi anche
indirettamente per
tutti Invece i pasti che vedono gli
animali coinvolti che per tutta la loro
vita prima della macellazione hanno
appunto mangiato questi vegetali e
pensando proprio Su questo fronte
Secondo me è importantissimo utilizzare
tale verità per rispondere a chi ci
accusa di essere dei mostri nemici
dell'ambiente che deforestano il
Sudamerica e sprecano 1027 litri d'acqua
per la produzione di soia in quanto
questa viene devoluta per la stragrande
maggioranza
al bestiame che dovrà appunto
sostentarsi con essa ripeto prima della
macellazione questo bestiame però è
anche esaltato come modello di
economicità che ottimizzerebbe dei
terreni altrimenti non coltivabili e che
fornisce in cambio un
grande grandissimo
alimento fonte di proteine Peccato che
se questi campi
se utilizzassimo al meglio i campi che
sono destinati per l'appunto a diventare
risorsa per il mangime dei miliardi di
animali che vengono macellati ogni anno
potremmo sicuramente
optare per delle piantagioni bambini più
sostenibili come per esempio i fagioli
che richiedono molta meno irrigazione
rispetto alla soia e rispetto ovviamente
alla produzione di un hamburger e a
parità di 100 grammi presentano le
stesse proteine di un pezzo di carne
rossa e in più non sono al contrario suo
cancerogeni di tipo 1 pensiamo agli hot
dog pensiamo agli insaccati A proposito
di nutrizione Senza scomodare casi e
catastrofici di persone che urlano allo
scandalo perché
sono rimaste veramente colpite da
notizie di genitori vegani che hanno
lasciato morire di fame i propri figli
oppure
persone che raccontano il loro essere
state vegane per un mese e scampare da
morte una certa ritornando onnivore
l'academy of Nutrition and dietetics ha
stabilito che la dieta vegana è adatta a
tutti gli stadi della vita ed è anche
incredibile ed è anche consigliata per
gli sportivi per gli sportivi Infatti
vediamo per esempio che si annoverano in
questa lista di persone nel mondo dello
Sport di atletiche hanno deciso di
passare al Plant anche Venus Williams
campionessa del mondo di tennis e Carl
Lewis Comunque sia io voglio essere
molto chiara questo discorso non parla
per pochi questo discorso non è diretto
solo a queste eccellenze che in un certo
senso trasversale potremmo anche
considerare in un'ottica di privilegio
perché è vero È bruttissimo pensare e
soprattutto sono molto molto arrogante
che tutte le persone possano diventare
vegane vediamo per esempio chi soffre di
dca di disturbi alimentari che presenta
una furtissima selettività alimentare
che
fa sì che tra i loro comfort Food sia
presente Magari anche
un piatto a base di animali a base
animale oppure pensiamo a delle
popolazioni indigene delle popolazioni
in giro per il globo in generale
che hanno come principale modo di
sopravvivere la caccia quindi
Chiaramente
io non pretendo che diventino vegano e
non punto il dito contro di loro Mi
piacerebbe però rivolgermi a un pubblico
che è consapevole di avere i modi per
riuscire a sfruttare l'occasione e
quindi cambiare in questo senso la
propria vita anche sfatando dei miti che
riguardano più la sfera della
concretezza di tutti i giorni pensiamo
per esempio alla credenza per cui la
dieta vegana sia immensamente più
dispendiosa rispetto a quella onnivora e
seppur Si purtroppo è una realtà che in
Italia il latte vegetale sia molto più
tassato rispetto a quello animale e
siamo praticamente il paese in Europa
che si distingue per questa cosa uno dei
primi paesi in Europa che si distingue
per questa cosa c'è anche da dire che
la carne il pesce sono decisamente più
cari eccessivamente più costosi
dei legumi del dei vegetali in generale
quindi della frutta della verdura e via
discorrendo
Comunque sia so che ci potrebbe essere
qualcuno a dirmi che sono una bugiarda
perché in realtà nella dieta vegana
manca l'abi12 e questo è vero Se non
fosse che manca anche agli animali tanto
che devono ricorrere ad assumerla
tramite il loro mangime a cui è
addizionata artificialmente e però
ritornando un attimo su di loro no
concentrandoci su di loro Io credo che
la più grande mancanza di cui invece
soffrono sia il diritto di non essere
sfruttati per la produzione di derivati
infatti questo è il motivo per cui la
dieta vegetariana non basta non è
sufficiente
dovete sapere che negli allevamenti
intensivi le mucche vengono ingravidate
artificialmente e soprattutto
sottoposte a uno stress post traumatico
terribile nel momento in cui alla
nascita del cucciolo questo è da loro
separato per essere macellato e quindi
il suo latte poi sarà devoluto a la
produzione su larga scala nei
supermercati eccetera eccetera e quando
poi il corpo dell'animale non sarà più
in grado di offrire questo bene verrà
anche sospeso al macello diventando di
nuovo un prodotto e storie
raccapriccianti del genere Ovviamente
possono essere
Sfortunatamente sentite anche per quanto
riguarda i casi di altri animali polli
maiali eccetera eccetera
anche api Comunque sia io so anche che
la prima risposta che una persona
potrebbe dare avendo lo shock di
ascoltare questa verità è Va bene non fa
niente basta Non comprare dagli
allevamenti intensivi c'è sempre il
contadino
che è un osservazione che mi lascia
spesso perplessa e mi in un certo senso
sorprende perché non riesco a capire
come Effettivamente un soggetto arrivi a
provare pena a sviluppare un sentimento
di dispiacere nei confronti degli abusi
inumani che subisce un animale però allo
stesso tempo è d'accordo con il
lasciarlo morire con il farlu uccidere
quando può benissimo scegliere di
mangiarsi un Burger di lenticchie Anche
perché poi dobbiamo ricordarci che gli
animali vengono mandati al mattatoio
molto prima della loro durata di vita di
base Infatti per esempio un maiale
è trasformato in un salume a 9 10 mesi
quando invece potrebbe vivere libero e
felice per vent'anni
Comunque sia io vorrei aggiungere anche
un'altra cosa ovvero che le persone
quando si approcciano al veganismo lo
vedono sempre come una sorta di scelta
personale quindi un io non ti impongo di
mangiare la carne quindi perché tu mi
devi obbligare a diventare vegano quando
purtroppo non ci si sofferma mai sul
fatto che il vero obbligo che la vera
imposizione è far morire un animale
questo far passare la luce dei
riflettori
da queste specie da queste specie
vittime di violenza a noi esseri umani è
ancora più triste e ancora più grave nel
momento in cui poi
non facciamo nient'altro che dissiparla
e farla cadere nel disinteresse più
totale io non riesco a capacitarmi di
come per cambiare la nostra idea senza
finire in quei discorsi colloquiali
insopportabili in cui io rimango della
mia opinione tu rimani della tua eh
bisogni sempre pensare che le persone
hanno i propri valori le persone sono
testarde e si sentono facilmente offese
quando
in verità per rendersi conto di quanto
ci sia bisogno di agire adesso quanto si
sia bisogno di fare qualcosa per la vita
degli animali ora non dovrebbe essere
necessario aspettare che il discorso
venganormalizzato che così il discorso
venga considerato all'occhio comune
da discutere con urgenza esattamente
come si potrebbe fare con una bolletta o
qualsiasi altro problema della vita
quotidiana ed è assurdo Come veniamo
assorbiti dal sapore dal disimpegno e
dalla pigrizia della nostra tradizione
In effetti si potrebbe anche spiegare
questo fenomeno di
mancanza di interesse totale
parlando di un processo inconscio
chiamato dissonanza cognitiva che
consiste in una dissociazione mentale
che
vede separati fatti i dati
il dato di fatto che la persona conosce
da i suoi comportamenti così da
renderli giustificabili da renderli
accettabili ed è anche la motivazione
per cui non ci viene proprio non ci
passa nemmeno per l'anticamera del
cervello che effettivamente c'è qualcosa
che non va se noi abbiamo per migliore
amico un cane o un gatto e poi nel
piatto
mangiamo a mezzogiorno una bella
bisteccona intrisa di sangue
Quindi io mi chiedo pure no se sia
giusto in un certo senso fare dei
discorsi di colpevolizzazione delle
persone vegane che non hanno sensibilità
nei confronti di chi smetterebbe di
lavorare perché non potrebbe più vendere
la carne Partendo dal presupposto che
abbiamo degli esempi di riconversione
dell'Industria clamorosi fantastici
vediamo la Giacomazzi deiri Il più
antico caseificio della della California
che dopo 125 anni di attività ha
iniziato a passare al fronte dei latti
vegetali io non so se quelle persone che
si fanno questo scrupolo che provano
questa preoccupazione reagirebbero allo
stesso modo davanti a uno spacciatore
che non potendo più vendere droga
sarebbe
prodotto a vivere d'altro e lo so è un
paragone forte però Questa aggressività
io non mi sento neanche dire primerla
Perché trovo assurdo che per prendere
seriamente per iniziare ad ascoltare una
persona che parla di veganismo questa
debba per forza essere gentile questa
debba essere per forza accomodante debba
mettere a proprio agio il proprio
interlocutore Soprattutto perché se noi
abbiamo la pretesa di essere trattati
con empatia di essere trattati bene
dovremmo anche avere la coerenza di
rapportarci con la medesima umanità nei
confronti di persone che scendono in
piazza Ogni quando possono per la vita
degli animali che si sgolano per
difenderla e che magari sono anche
Andate a rincorrere dei camion pieni di
animali agonizzanti
dritti eh diretti verso Mmm l'inferno
verso la morte assicurata sapendo che
avrebbero potuto salvarne veramente
pochi e a me dà fastidio che ci voglia
un'esperienza così forte un'esperienza
così toccante per stimolare qualcosa nel
cuore nella coscienza delle persone che
poi la maggior parte delle volte si
rifiutano anche magari di vedere i video
di ciò che succede all'interno
degli allevamenti intensivi dei Macelli
e via discorrendo oppure anche essendone
consce se ne fregano altamente perché io
mi immagino un mondo un mondo ideale
dove avere davanti a sé un pensiero che
prima non si conosceva è il modo più
grande per far tremare la Terra è
l'occasione più grande per mettere in
pantalone tutta la nostra vita tutto il
nostro modo di intendere le cose e
rivoluzionarci per sempre e farlo per
sempre perché le domande a cui
rispondere sono infinite ed è per questo
che se qualcuno di voi ora mi volesse
chiedere cosa può fare per abbracciare
al meglio la causa antispecista la causa
di liberazione animale il veganismo io
risponderei che è necessario armarsi di
compassione E di logica per arrivare a
rispondere a chi ti dice A che servono
gli animali se non per essere mangiati
che servono a loro stessi per vivere in
libertà
[Applauso]